إذا كان لديك يومًا واحدًا فقط لتعيش
فيه ، فماذا ستفعل به أصبح مشهورًا من قبل
هوليوود ، فإن فكرة متلازمة جراوندهوج داي
بسيطة ، يبدو أن كل
يوم هو نفسه الذي تعيده مرارًا
وتكرارًا على الرغم من أنه ليس
تشخيصًا نفسيًا له  هو شعور
مألوف لدى العديد من
أخصائية علم النفس في كليفلاند كلينك سوزان ألبير تقول إنه
عندما نفعل نفس الأشياء مرة أخرى ،
يمكننا أن نشعر بالملل حتى أنك قد تشعر بأننا محاصرون ،
فنحن نعتاد على بيئتنا ونبدأ في
ضبطها على الجانب الإيجابي وهذا
يساعد عقولنا  للاسترخاء ، لا يتعين علينا
التركيز على كل شيء ، الجانب السلبي هو
أننا لم نعد نختبر الأشياء بنفس
الطريقة التي تصبح بها أقل حيوية وإثارة
يقول ألبرت إن كسر
الحلقة المملة يبدأ بالتركيز على الذهن كل يوم
كن حاضرًا عقليًا وجسديًا
يشعر بالذوق  المس ، انظر إلى هذه التجربة
كما لو كنت تقوم بها
للمرة الأولى ، إنها تتعلق بإيقاظ
عقلك ، لذلك يقول ألبرت جرب أشياء جديدة قابل
أشخاص جدد اذهب إلى مطعم مختلف
وتذوق طعامًا جديدًا تعلم مهارة جديدة جرب
هواية مختلفة أو خذها  رحلة إلى مكان
لم تكن قد ذهبت إليه عندما نقوم
بأنشطة جديدة لأول مرة تؤدي إلى
تشغيل مسارات عصبية جديدة في
دماغنا ، فإنها تشكل روابط جديدة وهذا
ما يترك هذه الذكريات الدائمة والحيوية
تخرج عن القاعدة يمكن أن
تساعدك على الخروج من  شبق الخاص بك